you  hey I'd be happy to help if I can here  you go ADA one slightly dented but still  functional radar beacon this will do  nicely and with any luck it'll help us  trace the mechanist signal remind me how  this beacon will get us closer to  tracing the mechanist signal each robo  brains radar beacon has unique  encryption so that it can't be traced  back to the source however acquiring two  additional beacons should provide me  with enough data to break the code so if  my theory is correct this beacon will  help us trace the mechanism signal don't  worry I'm sure it'll do the trick I  certainly hope so I'm going to begin my  decryption routine but it could take a  while in the meantime I've picked up  another Robo brain vegan signal it  should be the last one you'll need to  collect